I'm here with Bob from semi and today
we're talking all about knowledge graphs
how do they actually get the vv8 set up
yeah so there are two ways how you can
do that so one is if you want to try it
out or play around with it we have
docker containers available so you can
run with even on your local machine but
if you want to scale it to you know for
big use cases we have a helmet arts and
kubernetes class is ready that you can
just with you know with the push of a
button you can run it and out of the box
so let's talk about the the first case
where they just have a docker container
yeah how is it available to them and
then what should they do with it one of
the things that we do is that we have a
the machinery model so that is pre
trained that lives on docker hub also
we've hid itself lives on docker hub so
you just literally run a docker compose
up and you get everything and then you
start running it there's really nothing
more that you have to do and a question
that I got lost that people ask me like
yeah but why do I need to train it and
the answer is you don't we'll make sure
that's all happening for you we train it
down we train on on Google cloud we
deploy it to a docker hub that's it it's
just you click docker compose up take a
sip of coffee and you're good to go
so all of that made available to them
yes but then the second model is you
know you're kind of hosting that for
them right yes that is correct so we
also host it for them which to be honest
under the hood is pretty much the same
thing so it really depends on what
people want so they can use the
open-source version do everything theirs
themselves they can use the hosted
version where we hosted for them or we
have a model where we say like we help
you set it up on for example Google
Cloud and run it for you so when it
comes for you to actually build that
software how do you create it such that
it's available for everybody yeah so
there are there are actually three
answers to that so first we have of
course the model so what we do is we
created a pipeline that trains the model
in separate languages so we it comes in
a language what we do that starts on get
up where the where the service code
lives and when we make changes or when
we want to create a new bottle because
of course the data ever getting in is
also at for example Wikipedia is also
constantly growing we
to a Google cloud we train on CPUs that
has to do with the type of model that
were using in seconds we spin up this
tremendously huge machine I think we're
talking many dozens of CPUs we're
talking about I think eight hundred gigs
of of memory and it starts to pull in
all the data sources hundreds of
gigabytes of source material it is a
pre-processing it does a training it
compresses all of that into I think in
between one and a half and two gigabytes
of a model pushes it to darker up shuts
everything down and we're done how would
you say Google Cloud has kind of helped
you build that so are there two answers
to that so first it's more the on a high
level building this five years ago maybe
I mean especially ten years ago out with
maybe in five years would have been
impossible I mean it's just it's just
impossible to do it so these these
dozens of CPUs the amount of memory that
it would simply be impossible so we are
a small company we're a start-up and we
can just build this and not even just
once we can do it every month so the
fact that these tools are available to
us just a tea at the click of button or
or a comment in the headline that is
fantastic
more practically that is the way how
Google Cloud has organized the
infrastructure so we use the api's and a
G cloud a lot so invest scripts we use
g-cloud and and in other situations we
use the API ecosystem it's just it's
very straightforward and very easy to
use it's very easy to debug to
understand what's going well what's
going wrong releases of underlying
technologies like operating systems that
just comes all out of the box so it's
just if I just try to think how we would
have you know should have done this five
or ten years ago that's just that's
that's impossible I think so that's how
it helps us we talked earlier about how
people can use bb-8 whether they can use
the hosted model or they can set it up
what were the next steps for people who
are really interested in learning more
about we v8 and so they can go to our
websites that would be a semi dot
technology that you can find the
documentation but
and that's basically where they can get
started we are represented on all on
platforms Stack Overflow get up Twitter
well anything that you can think about
so and if people have questions or want
to engage then I'm looking forward to
meeting them well it's really exciting
to hear about the space so thank you
very much for coming in Bob thank you